hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with yamimash hello
everyone I'm yamimash yes that is
yamimash once again we're bringing you
the pain in horror and suffering that is
the gmod or maps and we've actually got
a report it I don't know some sort of
grumbling going on in the corner over
there but we got an actual good map
question quotation marks maybe I believe
so my one was good at least yeah if you
haven't seen it already go over to
yamimash his channel you can click on
his beautiful face over there to be
taken directly to it or look in the link
in the description below so let's get it
going me first
Oh lovely hey that guy yeah she did it
right yeah well it's a lady got this
sullen look on her face that's so sad
okay so I still hear that grumbling in
the oh I get it now she was looking at
the chicken my chicken is it it's not a
chicken it's what's known as a headcrab
ah so this door is locked and there's
something in here jumping in this box
oi jump in the box please jump jump in
the box oh I hope it squishes you yeah
did that work yeah no it didn't work get
out of the box you get the box yeah you
always made me down okay the door open
haha oh look wait no there was something
there there was something in the window
here
I saw it there's like wha hey oh I got
my volume turned like way up in my
headphones so everything is like
obsessively loud okay is a god oh I fell
in the hole Oh am I supposed to jump in
here yes please tell facts okay
alrighty thank you still hit I growling
I hasn't gone any quiet I know and it's
raining in this whole house that many
goodies and I don't though I've stopped
asking questions about these maps a long
time ago I need a key okay haha there's
got a stop hi are you alive Cobham oh it
is it's really good who's real fun look
like this that's such a good time
yeah okay uh he gay
oh [ __ ] alrighty then
alright you keeps you in I'll stay right
here I got your back okay thank you what
with that guy's kill him kill him kill
him kill him kill him kill him kill him
I tell them oh there we go
well this is turning out good so far Oh
a key and a baby doll hey can I have a
dog y'all be much I'm here with the baby
Oh baby I have a baby wrong - what's his
name
his name is Billy I'm gonna name him
little Yami
hey Betty Oh Pelly coma maybe I'm gonna
name him Yami baby I'm gonna feed him
bit its arm yes please freedom beer as
is the British tradition every time a
baby is born you shove beer down his
throat my god hey kill it I have one
hell I'm sorry I'm just holding Billy
yeah yeah Billy protected you from that
little yeah he looks me know what's
wrong with Billy oh he's all Saddam
he's always lost an arm he's never had a
night yes he was like I'm like um okay
oh come on that's so sad okay let me
through you know it was another one of
those things I hear a noise table I I'm
not gonna get a good out oh [ __ ]
I saw that well kill it I'm not very
good at aiming okay actually the
shotguns sucks I don't know why ah hello
you got four words Oh what the hell Oh
why were the chairs on the ceiling I
don't know
and then these weird zombies popped up
out of nowhere
oh this looks again it's that same dummy
they keep popping up oh oh oh it's
another lady just sitting there
it's another one ah go say hi to I wanna
I know what happens
whoa you go down there oh is this you
this is your video Oh
we had an agreement I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna
I'll stay Roy oh I don't wanna get guy
fought I don't wanna aren't you
following me huh
I don't wanna okay it's nothing it's
nothing all right
it's nothing it's nothing it's just it's
just it's just too much painting on the
wall ha ha I'm going to see the lady ah
there we go
well where's the lady she turned into a
robot
look I pressed the button where'd the
lady go she's humming it hmm
uh-huh there's a lot on these okay push
you see that that's my ultimate weapon
Oh kill me
you gotta kill what montage it feels so
much like ecology right now yeah yeah
totally say hi to the lady I don't even
know if you can get to that lady I'm
gonna go back hey hey I'm wait Han I'm
gonna go back now she doesn't do
anything how do we get to her those guys
we get this symbol on the wall I think
hmm Matt would you like a fresh beverage
oh yes please yes I just water for me
okay maybe they don't work what what is
this bull is there some secret behind
him I don't know I don't know candy them
all right then we're moving forward all
right just a few more zombies to mop up
all righty
well I still some shocking zombie
apocalypse Oh
all right follow me zombie or Yami
i'ma come in dub dubby dubby dubby the
wheels [ __ ] that was amazing I know
right thank you God all right I am I am
too Pro to be beaten by what the what
how's that no you thought that was the
end of it
impossible oh those a short 100 tops 10
minutes I didn't even know that was like
five minutes maybe serious I've I'm I
feel cheated out the rings are so high
haha
actually you know what we should do you
know we should do I'm gonna we're gonna
cut the video here are not cut it don't
stop recording or anything but I'm gonna
cut it in processing I'm gonna load up
death house - hmm and see what happens
from there okay as I know P I know
people want to see death house too by
the way watch Yami's first before you go
see this so click right everywhere
there's gonna be annotations popping up
everywhere to go to Yami's video watch
it first before this one watch the video
water hi everyone we're back hi yamimash
how you do know oh hi how's it how's it
going have you watched that video I bet
they haven't if you have in it click
that link cuz this won't make sense
I hear that phone remember that phone oh
the guy on the phone yeah I think that's
him okay hi there which guy oh that
I may be okay anyway so we're walking
through alright I suppose I should get
the phone again cuz it was me last time
no no no no I got oh here's a phone oh
my god I'm gonna get it now where are
you oh let me come here I'm gonna guy
get hello hi yeah hello mate not you an
insane man prowling the darkness okay
you it's me yes yummy Oh gorgeous
okay no yummy
no don't get now why did you go down
there oh [ __ ] here oh [ __ ]
Yami I think you're just trapped forever
um okay you stay there and I'll go try
to divine jumping by ah me oh oh it's
the face hang on it I see a face go
towards the face Mac hang on I got that
wait whoa whoa close you see those
scribbles on the walls
I can't I'm like seeing the other side
oh so I'm coming cool
no way is so weird you can't see it
hahaha I know you can't Yami or you will
soon maybe wait hang on you're not gonna
do something to me I wait I'm trapped in
a room oh no oh no waiting it's open now
no way okay so wait a minute here so are
you out makes sense
are you out oh the face oh is it a big
clown face Frank
that one like robot okay good I'm in a
padded room hi oh hi where did you get
here I just decided to all for a door
and now we just go back out okay alright
then there's two fans fast this one is
it's pointing arrows to the right Oh Oh
as a key in this one monkey oh I think a
key is what we need right I'm just gonna
go I'll go I'll go I'll go for it I got
it I got it
you'll be okay mark nothing's gonna
happen we'll follow me I'm not following
you follow me uh-huh okay I got the key
I found the key all right
what's over here oh my gosh bugger is
one of these days a box is gonna kill
you mom oh whoa whoa whoa whoa oh hi was
it going I don't think we're supposed to
be here this looks like a problem uh-oh
let's go back I don't think we're
supposed to be here no I think you're
wrong okay let's go back okay you have a
really bony bloody ass thank you
I've worked hard to get this one and
only and bloody okay I'm gonna go
through this vent here but the air is a
point in the oven I know it's a trick
it's trying to trick us to going the
wrong way and we're supposed to go this
way
it's it Oh see this door opened and now
there's another vent it's too many vents
of my liking I still hear a lot of those
noises oh my god whoa whoa what is that
oh is that it's really ugly hey
everyone's beautiful and good let me out
what ow don't worry mark oh oh what oh
just face it it's the same faces before
we have to go back Oh anyway we're just
going in circles whoops
well goop house to everyone this doesn't
seem nearly as high quality is the first
one
it could get better could be it okay um
where else are we supposed to go then we
got the King got the key you should go
back when in the padded room just go
back this way no that's still locked I
guess we got to go the way I thought it
was like we weren't supposed to go this
way but apparently we are huh strange I
still don't know how you got from where
you were into that padded room but I
guess that doesn't matter now so down
the wall with my crowbar well good for
you my gosh okay so we got these dark
chasm it's gonna happen so it's gonna
happen nothing gonna what
okay hey hey what wha well you're a my I
see your ass is in my face Yami he's
talking to us what we couldn't make it
out what oh that's it how's it ha ha ha
ha
all right then convenient ha ha well I
guess that's all then hey why why why
yeah yeah yeah yeah ha ha I got you ok
so that's it that's it that's it I guess
yeah
by the way hey everyone drink relentless
yes this sponsored by relentless okay so
that's a nice segue into getting cross
channel stuff right cuz you gotta see
you're forced and then in order to see
the end part of it they got to see my
video first so yeah that was really
smart
yeah we totally planned that everybody
so professional I'm gonna kill myself so
that I can join back with is yeah yeah
hello hi okay so thanks everybody so
much for watching
um I guess you've already checked out
Yami's video so if you haven't link
still in the description it's the same
video so thanks again everybody for
watching thank you yamimash for joining
thank you uh-huh and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
Wow
Oh
the football shape
oh this was a ripple of all this is
totally written on the ball I do with my
husband who circles in a square too
yeah